we have Butterfly Wonderland with Rob
and Miranda Schneider who's ready for a
daddy-daughter trip you can do it
[Applause]
you do know that your dad is known as
like a very funny guy right yes do you
think he's funny yeah
how many movies have you seen of mine
completely half of one half of one which
one was it the animals
[Music]
why did we turn it off because your
sister started what crying
Miranda's nine and definitely giving up
the goods on her dad that's why we
traveled to meet the two at this
Butterfly habitat in Phoenix Arizona
which is also where they shot one of the
key scenes in their new film together
daddy daughter trip a heartwarming
comedy about a father-daughter Duo who
hit the road for a vacay the family
can't afford
able we're going to gas station
Rob's other daughter singer Elle King
makes a cameo and Adam Sandler's wife
Jackie plays Miranda's mom in the film
hitting Select theaters tomorrow go
spring break
Adam is um you know he was so sweet it
was a family affair one of the most fun
movies I've ever worked on and my
favorite co-star right here you want to
be just like dad in real life yeah yeah
I hope I can be just as funny oh any
good parent as he is all right let me
just pay for this one
[Music]